Now we're going to go ahead and look at
the code for defining an entity. Let's imagine that
you want to store entities of kind recipe. Maybe
you like chocolate cake, especially chocolate cake covered in
strawberries and sprinkles or maybe you prefer pavlova. This
one looks really good with kiwis and strawberries. For
whatever kind of cake you like, your recipe needs
some properties. Obviously it has to have a name,
a list of ingredients, some instructions, perhaps indicate the
number of servings. And you can say whether it's vegetarian
or not. This might not be quite so important
for cakes but could be really important for like, say,
lasagna. If you use the native App Engine data
store low level Java API. You need to create entities
with instances of the entity class. However, the entity class
is final so you can't subclass it and you can't
add fields to it. Fortunately for us, there's an
open source library called Objectify. Objectify makes it easier
to work with entities by allowing you to define
classes that represent entities of a particular kind. Then
you simply add fields to the class for each
property that you want your entities to have. So,
here's the code for the Recipe entity class. Notice
the imports, these packages provide the objectify functionality for
defining entities. Okay, next, notice this
@Entity annotation. This annotation indicates that class
represents an entity. The class name is the kind of the entity. So
here we define the entities of kind recipe. This entity class has the properties
recipe ID, name, vegetarian, servings, and so on. When you use objectify,
every entity class must have one, and only one property, marked with the @ID
annotation. This is the entity's ID and it's used to help uniquely identify
the entity. You see that the rest of this class is just a
regular old Java class. It could have
more constructors and methods if you wanted.